[Musique]
et c'est parti pour 4 jours de
compétition
tous les clubs de l'île ont répondu
présent pour cette sixième édition du
tournoi international de badminton
plusieurs objectifs en fait c'est
redynamiser le bennington à la réunion
ce tournoi a été arrêté pendant cinq ans
c'est aussi préparer l'avenir c'est
aussi redonner envie goût au sport à
travers la période sanitaire qu'on
traverse donc il ya plein d'objectifs
mais avant tout ce tournoi a toujours
été créée dans l'objectif de faire une
grande fête du badminton dans l'océan
indien
malheureusement cette année on est
bloqué au niveau des liaisons aériennes
mais ça reste ça doit rester la grande
fête du badmington dans l'océan indien
une grande fête qui accueille 158
joueurs en lice pour plus de 320 matches
en simple en double et en mixte
les joueurs pratiquent leur sport ce
vendredi ce sont les jeunes qui occupent
les terrains c'est du plaisir voilà
j'étais venu là pour gagner simplement
je suis ma muse et c'est le principal
et si je perds en club on joue souvent
sur les comptes les mêmes personnes et
là ça me permet de jouer contre des
nouvelles personnes à découvrir un peu
mon jeu j'ai participé au tournoi parce
que déjà j'aimerais bien m'améliorer et
jouer avec la pression avec des gens qui
nous regardent et c'est l'organisation
invité cette année des joueurs de
l'équipe de france classée parmi les 100
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux et une
joueuse internationale
ils commenceront la compétition à 19h
pour un tournoi de haut niveau te donner
des étoiles les deux étoiles dans les
yeux à tous nos joueurs réunionnais qui
vont pouvoir côtoyer pouvoir discuter
avec les joueurs de l'équipe de france
qui vont pouvoir taper des volants et
des joueurs l'équipe de france je pense
que de tous joueurs et tous compétiteurs
même loisirs a envie de pouvoir côtoyer
les joueurs comme ça qui sont les a vus
hier très accessible très à l'écouté
très avenant donc
donnez des données des étoiles dans les
yeux à tout le monde que je crois que
c'est important
[Musique]